Hi John! Hi John! Hi John! Hi John! Hi John!
This is making my balls cold! Hi John! Howdy
Johnny-boy! Hi… John… I guess? Good morning,
John! It’s Wednesday, January 31st.
The University of Georgia’s mascot is a
bulldog, so they covered the town of Athens
with bulldogs, and I covered their bulldogs
with myself. That’s a pretty normal thing
to do on a Tuesday evening, isn’t it?
In keeping with the tradition of movie magic-ing,
that was actually not filmed today, nor was
it filmed yesterday. It was filmed on the
day of my last video, but I had already filmed
the intro for that day in Asheville, so I
had to use that day’s footage for today’s
intro. So I’m not actually in Athens anymore;
I’m in Orlando, Florida. Welcome to Orlando,
where everything sucks. Okay, not everything
sucks or else I wouldn’t be here, right?
So the people, some of them, are very cool.
John Green, as you are playing the Nintendo
Wii, I can only assume that you have finished
your first draft of your book. Because there
is no way you’re gonna finish your first
draft of your book after you get a Wii. Very
exciting news that you finished your first
draft of the as-yet-unnamed third book of
John Green, and also very good news that you
have a Wii
Which leads me to the punishment. Someone
suggested that you send me your Wii as punishment,
ohohohhh, yeah! But! I am not that much of
a jerk. So, getting down to business, I have
to come up with a punishment, and I got a
lot of them to choose from. Some people are
calling you a standup citizen for agreeing
to do the punishment before I told you to
do the punishment. But you called me on the
phone and tried to convince me that it wasn’t
a punishable offense that you sent me that
e-mail. I just wanted to set the record straight
on that one.
Now the e-mail wasn’t really a personal
communication, so I can see why maybe a little
bit there’s some leeway there, so I’m
not gonna give you the worst punishments possible.
In fact, I think I’m gonna give you a choice.
And I honestly don’t know which one you
will choose, but you have to do one of the
two following things: Grow your facial hair
for a week, and then wax your chin, or fill
a large bowl with Ben and Jerry’s ice cream
and then watch it melt.
Additionally, I agree with the majority of
our commenters that "in my pants" is funnier
than "in your pants" when it comes to Everyone
Poops. Everyone Poops in My Pants is a sad
story, whereas Everyone Poops in Your Pants
is a funny story. And I think our viewers
will agree with me when I say that funny stories
about poop aren’t as funny as sad stories
about poop. And I am waiting in great anticipation
for the picture book Everyone Poops in My
Pants.
John Green, I will see you tomorrow.
Another Brotherhood 2.0 special feature is
upon us, and this one is slightly disturbing.
You might want to cover up the kiddies’
eyes; I am not doing what it looks like I’m
doing to this bulldog.
Katherine: Ride it! (William Tell Overture
plays)
Katherine: How do you feel about what’s
just happened to you? That wasn’t very comfortable,
was it?